I've seen you like over the last few
years kind of just be tired of the
character tired of like yo guys I get it
I get that this happened I get that this
happened right I get who I am I get what
I've done but I also got a a family I
got people who you know I you know is
that something that you've
because you know at the end of the day
like you said like people kind of when
they think of Ray J they think of
certain things in their head yeah sex
tapes or they think of reality TV or a
crazy Breakfast Club call which was
legendary by the way
um but you're like I said thank you I
mean some of the things people say that
I've done is like man I've seen this or
you did that man that [__] was dope my
God thank you man but I just think that
like you're you're so much more than
that like do you feel like now you're
finally kind of getting into a space
where you're just kind of at peace like
hey people are gonna look at me how
they're gonna look at me but I kind of
know what's going on you know what I'm
saying yeah I mean you know I always
focus on the business of everything it's
always a strategy behind it I am burnt
out of being Ray J though that's why I'm
like I've been telling the team like we
got to take the J off at some point this
year and just go with raytron or Tron or
Ray because uh Ray J comes with a
different kind of like stigma
just a whole year it's a whole nother
like life
um and it's lived oh [__] I'm I'm lit
forever I mean that's you I'm sure you
saw Vin Staples and his his
proclamations about you did you see that
you had to have seen that I've seen that
I did I did some stuff with Vince um
after that like we did something for his
uh his uh I think it was his YouTube
channel but we did some funny stuff
together
I do think he's right though because I
think that when it comes down to like
what we're seeing nowadays right like I
think of uh you know like the blueface
Christian show and and that whole
network like Zeus Network I'm like yo
this is all like
this is like a son of like what Ray J
Like For the Love of Ray J was like a
show that kind of like changed
entertainment yeah like all the Antics
aside yeah like you kind of kicked off a
whole wave of like
just that we see now yeah like reality
is is booming like we've been in the
game for like a decade plus and now
we're starting another
Ott platform it's called the Tronics
Network and um we're doing a a
compilation we like we we doing a bunch
of like content it's similar to the
stuff that we did um at Zeus and at
Viacom where we at now and we I got
shows on every Network three on Zeus
I mean I don't I can't count on the
other like linear networks but the new
networks should like take off in a crazy
way too but um yeah we've been we just
been working man everything been going
good do you have any uh ownership stake
at Zeus No no no no not at all I mean I
have equity in every show that I did
right
um what shows were you behind there well
we we kicked I mean in my opinion we
kicked the whole network off with uh the
conversation I think that was the first
super successful show that uh Zeus had
and then we we doubled back with one
more chance uh princess myself and
Jackie long and then we double back
after that and I connected the dots with
uh with the baddies so if you look at
the first season you see executive
produced buyers on the first season
um and and I think [__] I think that's a
[__] enough because that's all the
that's like I think with Jocelyn show
added in I'm kind of like the network
that's the powwow yeah I'm saying so you
know we just gonna do it again and get
in the game a different way have most
control over it I feel like it needs a
few um a few adjustments in the reality
as far as how loud it is I need some
some positive uh some positive endings
and some like you know lessons we can
learn from all the Ratchet [__] we might
do there has to be some kind of like
lesson and luck yeah the character Arc
yeah so so we want to provide that too
and give everybody a chance to eat and
own all that [__]
um on the new network that we dropping
so so you can have your own network
coming it's on the way it's on the way
it's on the way right it's actually
emotional tequila yes it's in motion
Anthem Calypso Calypso
yes
Amigos hey George Clooney got paid yeah
he did I was like I feel like I was one
of the last people to realize that that
is George Clooney's autograph on the
front of that bottle yeah that's his
and it's like oh George Clooney's Rich
yeah he did that because I feel like if
anybody won in the pandemic it was
casamigos
um most definitely
yeah you did you just do that he did it
you remind me of the Denzel movie Flight
oh yeah you're the drunk pilot
is there a cup around do we have cups I
think
oh you got kind of Thug you gotta take a
big sip of this one
yeah I think he's trying to convince you
to take a shot of diabetes to the head
first there you go
and then a little
oh yeah
yeah hey let me get that let me get one
of these lemonades to chase with let me
get a swing hey we might as well all
drink right now bro that's what you want
the blow out of paint what do you guys
think is better I'll eat a blue probably
200 calories of sugar
[__] my diet
cheers fellas we living life man hey so
tell me about the uh competition in the
bay this weekend where you guys are
going to be having people riding bulls
you know by Saturday we're doing a bull
riding competition at Westwood
um best Friday you know most style kind
of sexiest best Vibe you know and then
we gonna do in San Jose we're doing a on
Sunday we're doing myth day party but
you know so we're in the base Saturday
and Sunday oh [__] okay
okay
you know we about to like the bay in L.A
have always kind of been where we
started uh getting stuff popping so you
know we got to get our markets that have
always held us down right fully in song
with the song and then we gonna start a
little Tick Tock campaign too you know
so uh you know most creative
um most creative video on Tick Tock you
know we're gonna start doing 25 000
bucks and this is for an electric bull
riding competition yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and there's more to
come
man we just we just living life it's
like you know it we believe in the
record you know it's a great age it's a
great record we just got right now it's
just about getting the uh the eyes and
the ears the kids know that this even
out and then once they know it's out
it's like it's gonna do what it's
supposed to do you know but right now
that's why we're here let people know
it's solid people know we got a body of
music coming along with it you know with
the EP coming along with it and we we
just not playing we just want to make
good music and make good mom machine you
know just leave our Legacy and just just
catch a Vibe is this our first interview
um together proponent the song it is you
guys never did one 13 years ago no I'm
talking about right now for this one oh
you know if we did one like like human
interaction together we never did an
interview okay one four three it's our
first interview when you I was gonna ask
you Bobby when you're writing like when
you're a writer like you all right I
always wonder like what do you pick to
keep for yourself and what do you pick
to like give away man it's always been a
challenge like loyal to Chris Brown so
I'm supposed to be my song and then a
knick-knack wanted to give it to Chris
who produced this new song for you as
well right yeah and then shout out to
Knick Knack I was like me and Tyler
worked on uh loyal together Ty was like
nah bro I worked on that one for you
like that's your song and then Nick was
like no bro we gotta give it to Chris
man they got in a big ass argument I'm
like bro you can't like like and then he
finally convinced me I was like fine
Chris could have it and then time and I
convinced Tyler it feels like fine Chris
can have it and Chris went crazy with
the ball like and got I'm glad Chris
took it you know he made that song uh
Ultra smash yo you were shout out to
Chris Brown